if you enjoyed Ben Affleck's Batman in
the newly released Batman vs Superman
you may be happy to learn today that not
only will he play the part into further
films but he's also working on a really
cool script for a new Batman movie I'm
Kate and this is your gravel-voiced
batfleck news update in interview with
talent agency w Emmys co-ceos Ari
Emanuel and Patrick Whitesell whitesell
revealed that Affleck is signed up to
play the Caped Crusader in the two
upcoming Justice League movies and has
ideas for another film beyond that he's
contracted to do at least justice league
1 and 2 so at least three times wearing
the Cape whitesell said there's a script
that he's written it's a really cool
batman idea so that's out there as an
option no further details on the script
were divulged earlier this month Affleck
said in an interview with e w that
Warner Bros plans to make another Batman
movie but stopped short of revealing his
involvement there's definitely
willingness and a will and a desire to
make a stand alone Batman movie on the
part of Warner Brothers he said it's in
development and right now I'm really
focused on finishing live by night
that's where my focus is and I tend to
be a one movie at a time guy when I'm
finished with this movie then I'll focus
on my next movie and figure out what
that will be Affleck has been rumored to
be the studio's choice of director for a
standalone Batman film for sometime last
year it was reported that his deal with
the studio to play the character in
batman vs. superman also included him
writing and directing a future movie for
Warner Bros what are your suggestions
for the affleck directed batman script
let me know in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter I'm at how not to
draw thanks for watching and for your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot